kim kardashian is praising her estranged
husband kanye west on father's day yeah
the reality star shared this sweet photo
of the rapper with their four kids north
saint chicago and song and wrote
alongside the pick thank you for being
the best dad to our babies and loving
them the way you do happy father's day
yay i hope that they work really hard i
think they have good exam i i learned
from seeing both of my parents work
really hard and i think our kids will
see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path
kim's tribute comes just days after she
opened up about past struggles in her
and kanye's marriage on hulu's the
kardashians i respect that no one came
to me during my marriage and was like
are you good everyone let me have my own
journey and see that on my own and i
appreciate that but sometimes i like
look back and i'm like when do we jump
in
yeah the beauty mogul was consoling her
sister chloe shortly after learning
about her ex tristan thompson's
paternity scandal
while giving coco some advice kim
reveals she really tried to make it work
with kanye for their children's sake if
people knew what what my relationship
really was like i think they would be
like how did this last this week yeah
but i can live with myself knowing that
i tried everything humanly possible to
make a situation work and so i could
walk away being like absolutely
guilt-free and i feel like you could at
least say you had a family you tried
everything in your mind and you can look
your daughter in the face and say that
and since kim filed for divorce last
february she's clearly moved on with her
life including a new romance with pete
davidson pete is has got to be literally
the best human being i've ever met like
the best heart people always say like oh
he's so funny and it's like has to do
with how funny he is that's like
fourth on my list of why i like him
kim's been giving fans glimpses of their
relationship sharing these candid shots
from their recent trip to tahiti
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Laughter]
following their tahitian getaway a
source told et the two are super serious
and in love and are talking about their
plans going forward as a couple it's
always so much fun the source says that
pete being so great with her kids is
something she really loves and
appreciates and it's made her fall even
harder
kim and pete are very invested in each
other and feel closer than ever they had
an amazing time in tahiti and can't wait
for what the future holds
[Music]